at the conclusion of the Second World
War in Europe you'll know that Germany
was divided up into four occupation
zones along with Austria yet when Japan
was defeated in the Pacific Theater of
the war came to an end it wasn't divided
into occupation zones instead it came
unto the near exclusive domain of the
United States but why why wasn't Japan
divided into occupation zones so before
getting to the why you should know that
the original plan was to in fact split
Japan into four occupation zones much
like Germany although this time there
was to be no France the north of Japan
was to be occupied by the USSR the south
by the British this area was to be
occupied by the Republic of China and
the rest was to come under the control
of the United States I shall know this
never came to be in the primary driving
force behind this was unsurprisingly the
Americans who nobody argued with because
of their unique nuclear arsenal so as
far as US forces were concerned they
done the bulk of the fighting against
Japan and saw no reason why they should
be forced to share their defeated enemy
many in the US government felt that the
rest of the Western allies Britain
France and their colonies had done
little to help and frankly weren't in
the financial position to what keep I
much more than they already were it also
won't shock you to know that the
occupation of Germany in Austria was
already fairly tense especially between
Soviet and Western soldiers and there
was no desire to repeat that in Japan
furthermore Truman was a fundamental
opponent of communism and so we refused
point-blank to give any part of Japan
beyond South Sakhalin to the USSR since
he was unsure if they would ever leave
or whether or not they would start
spreading communism there he also
flat-out refused to deal with the French
since their role in the Pacific Theater
was minimal and Truman considered it a
big enough favor that France would be
allowed to take its colonies back so the
Soviets were keen on having a part of
Japan under their own occupation because
why wouldn't they while Stalin was happy
to regain South Sakhalin he was annoyed
that the USSR wouldn't be involved with
the occupation since he felt that even
if Japan was disarmed it would continue
to be anti-communist which to be fair it
was but the USSR was the only power that
the US wouldn't budge on because the new
Cold War as for the Republic of China it
wasn't particularly interested in
occupying mainland Japan says it would
take money and resources which you
couldn't spare especially when
considering the momentarily halted civil
war Chiang kai-shek was mostly concerned
with getting the island or Formosa back
along with Manchuria and he did get the
first one so beyond that there was
little more that he wanted now it
shouldn't surprise you that Britain was
always happy to
do a bit of occupying was very keen to
be given a piece of Japan for itself
although most of the actual occupying
was to be done by Australian in Indian
troops which is why when the Americans
had occupied the islands Britain was
given some areas of control and was
placed in charge of overseeing Japanese
disarmament now America's original
suspicions would end up being correct
and Britain would quickly leave Japan
because it was expensive and they were
broke and thus until 1952 Japan was
under the sole occupation of the United
States for the rest of the world having
little to no say at all I hope you
enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons James Bissonnette
the pastry section Danny Maloney Marvin
Castle Kelly moneymaker Rob Waterhouse
John bisko's moe James Castaneda Aaron
the whites Jordan long way Marcus ours
nur Gustav Swan Jerry lamb Dean John
Bailey calling Castleman Rashid Ali
spinning three plates filled oink-oink
Maggie Potts Kowski David Silverman Izzy
Lexi Schwinn Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell
Spencer Lightfoot and Winston K word